I know sometimes I see how far the
Adrenaline Junkies go and I'm like how I
kind of get it you I love you have a
little bit of that you have a little bit
of that but there's a certain moment
where like bunge jumping I I would have
been doing love to do that all day that
was so fun hell no I would never do that
would you do like I don't know what the
actual name is but the one where you
just jump off a [__] cliff with a
free
diving oh with a with a a paraglide say
something really bad oh that that just
seems like instant death paring I really
want what I really want to do that my
intrusive thoughts would take
why just you have a guy who steers it
for you cuz you you can't you mean the
squirrel suit thing
right [__] sick I want okay I want to
do that it looks so fun
all I got train I got a train I got a
train it looks cool but when I'm not
doing it yeah I would GL if you told me
like Conor we could hook it up you can
go and learn how to do it I'd love to
that be what I've always wanted to know
is how do you learn how to do something
like this because presumably it's an
activity if you [__] up once it's like
skydiving right you have to do x amount
of hours like tandem with a professional
and like really like learn how to do it
you have to do a lot of hours like lot
of these jobs like like like cave diving
requires hundreds of hours like of
experience that's how a lot of them
manag so it's just you just have to be a
hobby and do it with an instructor a lot
yeah it's really really you have to
really really be dedicated to it um but
obviously PS pretty well when you do it
when you do get certified or whatever
because no one else is [__] I think
the most extreme thing I would attempt
to learn or attempt to do is scuba
diving I really want to go scuba diving
but that's
it's kind of it's super dangerous pretty
[__] dangerous you go yeah it depends
how deep you go but how deep are we
talking even going like 40 m is really
really like that doesn't sound much that
sounds like 40 me is so much that's so
de stand
[Music]
up that's nothing yeah at which at which
point does sunlight stop penetrating
like it's like 5 m n yes well even like
even like free diving without okay first
of all you first of all with with scuba
diving at like 40 m you have just start
decompressing and that's the scary part
you just sit there in the water for like
an hour yeah you can't you can't just
you can't
just people do and they die that's beta
[__] Skillet you
it uh I'll Google the you while Google
cuz I've done in the Philippines I did
the thing where like you put on that
like water uh hel I saw that on your
Vlog and then you you go to that was 10
m and that was a lot on your body oh
really and it doesn't feel like like you
look up and it's like oh I'm not even
that far from but you just you feel that
pressure as you're going down like your
body just gets so heavy and I'm like I
can't imagine going double that at the
first 10 m water already absorbs more
than 50% of visible light that's at 10 m
yeah depths below 1,000 M receive no
light from the surface whatsoever you
said 40 for the we said 40 so [__]
idiots but the amount of I'm saying it's
it's already it's at 40 m I think it's
already really [__] d yeah it gets in
the water but there's so much [__] in
the water like dirt and stuff you're not
going to be able to see anything I don't
want to sco
there well yeah cuz it's like the amount
of just the amount it's not even the
sunlight thing or anything it's just the
amount of pressure on your body at 40 M
is so much for your body that if you
immediately like just come up to the
surface you get you get [__] up this
seems like the kind of thing I have no
knowledge of and that's why I'm just
like that seems silly just float yeah
just hold your breath come on what's a
big deal just swim up just swim up I'm
trying to find how long you'd have to
wait uh to I don't know how you you'd be
waiting which is the scariest part
because you're like what if something
goes wrong and you know you need to
decompress the it says according to some
sources the theoretical limit of human
body pressure underwater is 1,000 M
which is 100 atmospheres of pressure
that's like theoretical limit that's the
theoretical limit I me people people
dive to like aund something yeah um
which is crazy that's still insane yeah
well the reason why I think you can dive
off of breath way deeper and come back
up no issues then you can if you use the
tank cuz the tank uses different us that
it uses like a uh a nitrogen uh mix not
nitrogen um 60 M some I don't know what
what's in a scuba diving tank you it's
it's like a mix between it's a very
concentrated thing that helps decompress
you not decompress you like keep you
your head not hurting while you're
diving 79% nitrogen 21% off yeah it's
nitrogen okay I was right it's like a
nit and so then when you're coming up
the the you'd have like bubbles in your
blood otherwise you C too fast they [__]
you yeah it's really [__] scary your
blood boils what's simil as hardcore you
would doing I don't [__] a
sheep I would do
like sorry sorry Sor that's just in your
bloodline sorry sorry sorry sorry S I
feel you want to go skydiving right I
want to I want to do skydiving let's do
skydiving I could do like jumping off
stuff at
you do BU jumping yeah I would do jum so
F I feel like I judge you Joey but I I
yeah I'm not doing anything you want to
do bung jumping no dude it's so
f videos I wouldn't do bunge jumping but
I would do skydiving wait what I'm not
scared [__] that because to me like it
my my like whole thing of it is I am
more scared of like the awkward height
than I am like the really really high
heights you know what I mean I I kind of
yeah I kind of understand like I'm okay
like when people are like afraid of
heights right like there's lots of
different levels I feel like I'm Not
Afraid going on like an airplane like
even though you're a lot higher right
but I get the most nervous the most
nervous I get with Heights is when
you're like looking over looking over
like a 10-story building dude it's so
fun though that's I get and like do you
get that voice in your head that say it
would be cool to jump no my in my head
is that just me no in my in my head I'm
just like I better step away before
someone PES that's what's so good about
bun jumping is that you get that voice
and you're like let's do it and then you
get like you get this beautiful moment
where for about a second you are just
speeding up weightlessness and there's
not you feel nothing but just [__]
the ground rushing towards you it's so
cool that sounds terrible no it's
amazing it's such a rush yeah but like
I've had nightmares like that that's
amazing I want to it's so fun and then
and then you get the fun part of the
bungee where you get to fly it's just a
scene from inception right that's how
you that's how you get the kick you just
get jolted the away like to me Sky is
way less scary than bungee jumping for
kind of I think it's actually I think
skyd is also safer than bungee jumping I
would I think we that I'm pretty sure
there's more deaths in bunge jumping
heard as well well a lot of the places
where you can bunge jump um are not
uh the best regul Rocky Ravines well
it's it's kind of like some dude in his
cousin who bought a bunge cord and we're
like let's do it yeah yeah I would trust
Japan with bu Bungie dumping yeah Japan
is the one place I I'll definitely do BU
jump here
I but also like another big thing is
that you know if okay worst case
scenario something goes wrong in
skydiving versus something goes wrong in
bungee jumping I feel like they're both
bad they're both F they're both bad but
I feel like at the height you're jumping
at skydiving you're you're just like is
it's just instant death actually no it's
not is it not no because terminal
velocity so there's a certain point you
reach the max speed you could go which
is like I think it's how many stories is
it can you what is Max velocity for
falling off building I think it's like
uh 20 stories or something so it's like
this you jumping from like 50,000 the
same for your body Landing as jumping
from like uh we'll find out now um hey
and if you land in
trees all right if you land in trees
yeah but assuming like open field you
just going to give up yeah yeah I I feel
less stressed knowing that I have I can
do nothing to save myself oras if I'm
like you got to try or if if I'm jumping
off a cliff I'm like well is going to be
like the worst pain in my life but let's
just break my legs and most of my back
someone says some dude on a forum says
you'd reach teral lost in about four and
a half seconds of falling that's pretty
quick and half seconds so four and a
half let's say that guy's right which
you might but it's still pretty fast uh
yeah it's very yeah but like it's you're
saying like that's like mes an hour it
says yeah so that's like this you know
you jumping from a big building would
have the same effect on your body when
you land as jumping from a
50,000 right that makes sense so G you
would just find like concrete to fall on
or something you'd be like I just want
this over with just just like just like
make it quick make it isn't your best
bet there was a pool right next to it
would you not land in the pool no no you
die if you hit the pool oh [__] cuz the
surface tension of the water pool what
where should you land then uh you should
land on the ground and spread out your
body take the guarantee full damage
death is that like the elevator thing
where you're just supposed to lay down
yeah because your your all the force is
being distributed across your body I
heard you supposed to Landing trees
that's all I know I think trees is good
cuz you have a chance of like hitting a
bunch and stumbling before you are are
you if you're in like do you or is that
just in cartoons well I think if you can
any way you can kind of kill the speed
before you land as good even if it hurts
a [__] time because like someone what
was it that woman in the gorilla people
have survived she survived with the
gorilla suit when her parachute didn't
I'm not kidding Google this gorilla suit
gorilla suit save skydiver type that in
that's so she was wear it was a charity
skydiving event I believe and she jumps
out with this gorilla suit yeah
uh and uh I think Colorado's one
on uh that one I think it was people do
live but you were just fall in like with
like same with like aanes like people
who grab onto like debris or something
really help like increases your chances
massively of surviving okay but here's
the thing hypothetical situation do you
try to survive in that situation or do
you just am I the only one who is just
like yeah I guess I guess my time is
come you're too content with dying you
just want to die it sounds like you want
okay okay if if you're in like if you're
in like a pain uh plane crash yeah do
you like just you know go to the brace
position and Brace position all the way
if there's if there's a one shot chance
I can survive awesome I'm taking look
around everyone doing the braak and what
a [__] is stands
up I'll be like guys well it's been a
good run let me just please that's the
only
time I I I never I never I've never
smoked like cigarettes but the one time
I think I would smoke a cigarette is if
I know I'm about to die all right well
[__] it who's going to
lie did you feel like an appropriate
response to dying you know I had a
moment where I was trying to find like
what to do in all these like
hypothetical scenarios and it was so
irritating trying to find the answers
cuz you it's like yeah you're probably
[__] cuz even if you survive a plane
crash right are you're flying over the
ocean yes which makes it immediately
[__] impossible you're just done and
then the question is in my head I'm like
do I have do I have it in me to want to
survive once I survive this crash that's
what I'm saying do I want to go through
that all people trying to find me do I
want to have to survive this sounds like
a [__] bull Lake I'm going to this
just sounds like too much work I'd
rather die instantly actually you know
what I'm on God side now [__] this damn
just a [__] hassle is that yeah I
remember there was one where it's like
just reset the
server if you fall through ice yeah I
was like okay what do I do like that
could happen like ice Lake you walk in
an ice Lake you fall in what do you do
they're like oh grab your ice piics to
pull yourself up I'm like if I I clearly
don't have those in this scenario get
your go go [__] out machine and get the
[__] out of there I think you just would
grab both sides if you can hopefully and
then well you slay down
yeah get a leg in I don't know what what
you do just cry I think he just [__]
at that point it's like have you seen
that video of the guy who's trying to
swim under the ice to the other side cuz
they put and the guy can't find it and
his friends are like slamming the CHP
like here you [__] that is anxiety
D I feel like there are some life or
death situations that you know I feel I
could survive where do you draw the line
then name name name a life and death
situation you survive 10 out 10
like even though even though it's said
like sign says I won't I feel like I
could just Survive by just the ego of my
own way of thinking like okay like what
give me give me jump jumping off a
bridge
right I like what bridge like Golden
Gate Bridge Golden Gate Bridge you
survive you no you don't survive I feel
okay I feel like you know what everyone
tells me surface tension is a thing but
I feel like wiggle your legs right
yeah just just like if you know just
like make yourself into like a [__]
pencil or something I feel like I I get
it just like you would break your arms
or legs at best that's that's what
that's what science says who trust
science to me water go splash that's
what I'm saying right some people
believe in the I think it's a I think
it's a myth but they throw a like a rock
or something to break the surface break
but I think it's a myth I think it's
actually I think that was proven in
Mythbusters this episode yeah okay yeah
but I saw this guy who broke recently
broke the the highest freef fall into
water record can you all this it's like
type in world record free fall into
water it should come up have you ever
had this thought where if you were in
like a like a elevator that dropped if
you just jump at the last moment yeah
obviously that's the only logical thing
to do yeah right right you definitely
survived that right no you're supposed
to lay down that's what I learned but
it's that's not fun i' rather just try
jumping
Jesus if it's frame perfect I think I it
was you can get away with it it's skill
is really angle perfect angle perfect
and frame perfect just no no one's just
achieved it yet oh yeah four days ago
you have to pause buffer
as50 M hour I'll put in the grp I'll put
in the grum higher than that stronger
I'll put I'll put it in the group so you
can show the guys uh what is this your
uh Googling Corner this is the guy look
at this look at this free fall jump
let's I want to see gone do you reckon
you survive this all right send it
to how you get it on that was a
Norwegian um yeah of course it's [__]
of course it's because they have nothing
to
do what do the swedes do what do they do
we play video games move to Japan play
video games leave Sweden that's why
there's so many swedes online there's
nothing else to do actually that's true
we have the same problem whenever
whenever I played Cod back in the day
there was always a Norwegian or
Scandinavian person that was just so
good at it and you're like [__] you
there's nothing else to do yeah I don't
know I don't know how the [__] you got
on that tangent basically Okay g you're
not [__] surviving no like I know I'm
not but I feel like you feel I actually
you know what I think I could what the
[__] is this a dumb idea spreading well
that's trash taste okay make sure your
kid does not watch Trash T Jo we what
are you
surviving um kangaroo attack like what
what what what is something what is a
situation someone says is like dangerous
but you're like I think I could come out
of this a bear attack a bear attack I I
think if a bear is right in front of me
I think I get out of it I don't think I
die I know you think that I I don't know
if the bad I don't know if the bad
thinks that I think that see one thing
you have to understand about Conor is
that he's very uh like he has a lot of
confidence in things I've noticed that
I'm going to scream at this
[__] bear until he leaves me
alone you know different typ of bears
bro I scream at all of them well then
you're D yeah I
win i'
win I'd
win Connor is the [__] in a
zombie apocalypse who's like I'll begin
the army goes out and immediately dies
guys I got bit is it
bad kill a few zombies
though K is still good pretty
yeah I'll be fine no I'd win I'd win I
ran so you could all war
yeah